hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar glassware
washers and result reliability
wash worry away i am jennifer woods of
labrutz and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by labconco to learn
more
visit labconco.com let's get started
before we begin i would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speaker jordan
henderson
product manager at labconco corporation
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
jordan you may now begin your
presentation
hi my name is jordan henderson i am the
product manager here at live conco for
glassware washers and water purification
today
we're going to have a little
presentation over glassware washers and
result reliability
and washing away any worry that may
be encountered in various laboratory
environments
on the agenda specifically for today
we're going to discuss
the impact and potential sources of
carry over contamination
identify and discuss highly sensitive
analytical methods
uh that will be and could be impacted
by sample carry over identify and
discuss common laboratory contaminants
really the causes of
potential contamination and then we're
going to discuss how implementing a
laboratory
glassware washer can help provide
consistent repeatable
reliable results
so really the first question to discuss
is what is
carryover so this is just a basic term
used to describe a type of sample
contamination
so really there are two types when
discussing sample
contamination you have sample the sample
and sample to sample is when a previous
sample
is actually present in subsequent runs
a lot of the times this will look like
ghost peaks and blake runs after the
subsequent analysis
this will also result in potential false
positives
the other type of sample contamination
is going to be your reagent to sample
contamination
this is more commonly found on high
output
continuous run instrumentation
so really the next question to ask is
why as a laboratory professional should
i be concerned
with sample contamination well really
i mean it's just a very serious issue
when it comes to the currency of the
laboratory the quality of your results
is paramount
obviously sample contamination can
result in errors
in analysis you get enough of those to
stack up on you
it really calls into question the
reliability of the results that
you and your laboratory is putting out
and that was going
going to really take um a hit towards
your lab
laboratory's quality um finally
when it comes to decreased quality and
reliability that's going to essentially
cost
laboratories time and money
in a previous life i i worked as a
clinical laboratory scientist
here at local hospitals here in the
kansas city area
and we were constantly concerned with um
sample carryover reagent carry over how
it impacted
there were the quality of results that
we were putting out on a nightly
or i'm sorry on a daily basis
from a purely clinical standpoint
it could impact just the overall
cost of consumables for sample
collection
time and money it takes for med techs
and clinical coordinators to identify
sources of those contaminations
retraining and then even you're putting
out results that
are affecting patient treatments and
patient outcomes and that can affect
their bottom line as well
so i know that's a specific example but
i think it's the overarching message is
it's important to outline that
when you're introducing variability and
contaminants
into highly sensitive analytical methods
um
that tends to snowball the exact same
way so
so it's important to identify uh
potential sources where contamination
can essentially show up and
the first place i would want to look at
is just the general laboratory
environment
there are specific environmental factors
such as humidity temperature
and the presence of light that can
adversely affect
samples that are trying that you're
going to use for analysis
molecules and compounds may try to grab
excess moisture in the air which could
have negative effects
on the quality of your results
temperature will also play a role
in the accuracy and
percentage yield that you're looking for
when it comes to certain reactions
low thermically labile molecules
generally will break down in the
presence of
higher temperatures then there are also
molecules and compounds that are
photosynthesis sensitive
some examples of these are some drug
compounds like the
digoxin and diazepam
also vitamins like folic acid and
other b vitamins tend to be
photosensitive there are also
balenogens urobilinogen porphobilinogens
that will break down on the presence of
light
so it's important to obviously protect
those uh
from from
too much light so really the overarching
point of this is to be aware
of your laboratory environment
temperature
presence of light humidity all those
things so we can
remove variables when it comes to
analysis
another potential source of
contamination is the use of substandard
reagents
ultimately when using substandard
reagents
this just presents an opportunity
to present additional impurities into
your reaction or your workflows
during your analysis oftentimes
on laboratory professionals we'll use
old or expired reagents obviously this
this isn't recommended
the use of calibrators and qc material
obviously will
will justify whether or not the reagents
that you're using in the process
will are within the realm of usability
also fair to say improper reagent
preparation is also
a source of contamination a prime
example of this
is in the lab i would make up anti-10a
or
other coagulation qc and calibrators
that stuff was very specific had a very
short
stability and it was very receptive to
how
um specific you made or followed the
package instructions to make up those
qc and calibrators that obviously can
vary from person to person
and tech a versus tech b
could make something entirely different
and that could produce a different
result for you
finally oftentimes laboratories
have to make cost cutting measures
sometimes that is
purchasing reagents from a lesser
reputable dealer
using less quality products obviously
will impact
the quality of your reaction as well so
just something to be aware of
another place to look when it comes to
potential sources of
contamination are going to be laboratory
professionals themselves
first and foremost the lack of ppe
being used in laboratories could
potentially lead
lead to additional contamination
not using rubber gloves face shields
disposable masks lab coats all can
can lead to the introduction of fibers
and samples
coughing so microbes other aerosols
things like that as i mentioned before
another source of contamination are
just the variation between tech to tech
and how
workflows are performed reagents are are
reconstituted
qc calibration is run also worth
mentioning that instrument contamination
and by this i'm really meaning how
pipettes other volumetric things are
used when you're making up these
reagents
are used they shouldn't be shared
also technique is very important if
you're bold pipe heading you can
essentially
aspirate up
reagent from one workflow and then use
that same bulb
to draw up an additional
reagent and that passes that along
into the analysis introducing that
reagent
to sample contamination also uh worth
mentioning
that visitor entry is something to be
aware of
that just allows for an increased
potential
exposure for the outside environment so
again
always be aware of just limiting certain
factors when it comes to
really protecting your sample from
potential contaminants
now we get to the crux of it samples are
often
stored transported reagents are mixed
stored transported in reusable
borosilicate glassware
so all of those potential contaminant
that i previously mentioned
are being funneled into these things
residual chemical contamination
i for example you know previous reagent
remaining in this glassware and then new
reagent
is being placed in and we're then
contaminating that reagent with old
reagents and using it to do analysis and
then residual sample contamination as
well
the same principle dirty glassware
that had a previous sample in it isn't
getting cleaned enough
then we put a new sample in and then
that's going to affect the result
quality later on down the road
so we've discussed sources of
contamination
now i think it's it's important to
discuss some of those highly sensitive
laboratory procedures
that are going to be severely impacted
by
by residual contaminants the first three
so
high performance chromatography ultra
high performance
liquid chromatography and super critical
fluid chromatography are all
liquid chromatography methods that
are still operating on the same basic
principle
then we throw in mass spectrometry which
uh combined with liquid chromatography
principles
is a highly analytical highly sensitive
method and then of course polymerase
chain reaction
is also very sensitive to contamination
so high performance liquor
programmatography is just a tech
and it's just an analytical technique
used to separate identify
and quantify compounds in a mixture
this is generally found in analytical
laboratories um
so the general hp lc procedure
involves pump moving solvents containing
unknown mixture which is also known as
the the mobile phase
through columns containing absorbent
materials which is known in the
stationary phase
this will lead to that mixture
interacting with that stationary phase
and then separating out compounds for
identification and quantify
quantification this is commonly found in
research
medical and manufacturing fields
moving on to the ultra high performance
liquid chromatography
this is still going to use the same
basic principles of mobile phases and
stationary phases
but they use a higher pressure range the
higher pressure range
is good for pulling out
lighter molecules and
increasing purity this is all commonly
found
in used in pharmaceutical fields medical
fields and then in research as well
moving on to the supercritical fluid
chromatography again
same principle as the hplc
however the mobile phase leverages co2
this is used in in the analysis of
purification of low to moderate
molecular weight
molecules thermally light
lay biomolecules as well again those are
just molecules
that tend to break down in the presence
of high heat
and then chiral molecules
and a chiral compound or molecule is
just
a superimposed molecule that
is a mirror image of itself a good
example of this is going to be ibuprofen
or warfarin which is an anticoagulant
this is a less used technique but it's
uh mostly going to be found
in the pharmaceutical industry
all right moving on we are now going to
marry on those
those liquid chromophob chromatography
techniques with max
mass spectrometry mass spect
spectrometry is really just
an analytical analytical technique
that measures mass to a charge ratio
they accomplish this
by manipulating the motion of the ions
by using
electric or magnetic fields
so you can use this technique for a
variety of compounds
they can be biochemical in nature
organic or inorganic so really just
covers it
covers everything this is commonly found
and used in
biotechnology environmental fields food
and agriculture fields and then cosmetic
and consumer industries
the the final sensitive technique that
we're going to go over is going to be
polymerase chain reaction
this is a simple technique uh where
laboratory professionals are trying to
amplify a target sequence of dna in our
rna
really the two most common types are
real time and quantitative
and those are just really characterizes
in point detection methods
they're used to analyze various
pathogens and viruses
some pathogens include e coli and
salmonella
some viruses could potentially
be hepatitis hiv norovirus
even some
molecular testing like jack 2s use pcr
this method is commonly found in biotech
medical food industry and research
settings
all right so now that we've talked about
those sensitive analytical methods
i think it's important to really kind of
just identify some pretty basic and
common contaminants that we can find
throughout the laboratory
so on a very broad level the residual
contaminants on glassware
tend tended or can be solvents
inorganic organic polar nonpolar
solvents so
anything that you use soren beaker they
could be acids or bases
weak acids and weak bases specifically
also could be
waxes and other lipid-based compounds
waxes are generally produced in during
alcohol extractions
and then also it's worth mentioning
detergent can be all can be a
contaminant
as well
other more specific contaminants it
could be fatty or
protein material these tend
to be contaminants consisting of plant
and animal based samples
a lot of the times you'll see this from
kelvil acid
acid digestions also you can see from
crude fat and fiber analysis
so this is going to be real big in the
food and ag and the food industries
essentially you're just taking samples
boiling them in acid
and then titrating them out to get the
nitrogen
percentage so
when those samples are undigested and
residual acid remains
obviously if those flasks are used again
and they're not effectively cleaned they
can have a negative impact on the result
quality that's produced
all right so now moving on to really
burton shard residues as well so this is
again a very
very broad group of contaminants
but it's something that
laboratories run into a lot
these burton charred solutions mixtures
obviously will result in result quality
issues if not
cleaned appropriately they tend to be
sticky
very hard to clean and removing these
residues
often require repeatable cleaning
workflow
so i would picture you know
a busy grad student running around in in
a research setting
trying to do multiple things at once and
they're heating up
i'm a solution and then they step away
for what seems like a minute but it's
actually a little bit longer
and then they forget about it and then
that solution has been evaporated and
it's
you know it's caked on glassware so
just be aware that that does happen and
we just need to be able to account for
that and clean it appropriately so we
can reuse that glassware
at a later date another contaminant to
consider are microbes and bacteria
can this type of contaminant affects the
useful life of reagents and buffers due
to the buildup of these colonies of mold
and other bacteria
potential effects range from
having an impact on stability of
suspensions and solutions
they could even act as catalysts or
inhibitors to various reactions
they also can lead to the formation of
unwanted reaction products
and additional impurities
so when it comes to dealing with this
type of contaminant it's always always
important to
to identify when it comes to glassware
washers the maximum
heat water temperature and drying
temperature but also
if you're talking from a sterility
standpoint
when in doubt it's always good to
autoclave
just to remind those for dry heat 160
degrees celsius
for one hour should do the trick but
when using
a steam autoclave 121 to 140 degrees c
is
the target temperature for that
i had mentioned previously that
detergent could also be a common
contaminant
residual detergent on glassware
can yield undesirable analysis results
as well
detergents have a very wide range of phs
all the way down to two so highly acidic
to
like our detergent is 13 to 14
so it's considered pretty alkaline
those changes in ph can affect the
reaction environment which will
yield on undesirable results
they also consist of varying chemical
compounds so you're just again
introducing potential impurities into
reactions which can have effect on your
results
and then also some of these detergents
are enzymatic in nature
so they can also
drastically affect the outcome of your
reaction that you're trying to control
when in doubt less is more i
there are a lot of people that will call
that i've spoken with saying hey we know
we're having
a lot of residue on our glassware and
that was most
that's due to putting in too much
detergent
so more detergent doesn't always equal
more clean
so moving on we're going to get into the
specifics of detergent just because
detergent glassware washers
have a very synergistic relationship
so when identifying the important parts
of
detergent the first one that comes to
mind is the surfactants
and what a cervactin is in detergent or
molecules that consist of hydrophilic
tails and hydrophobic heads
and essentially this is going to reduce
the surface tension of the water
moving on the next component is of
detergent is something called a carrier
and this aids in
dissolving soils and other contaminants
next are the chelators this molecule
basically binds to free metal ions in
the water
so this if you would think of like water
hardness
the chelators are going to help with
that and then the last
component of detergent is something
called builders generally these help
emulsify
buffer and soften contaminants
that are going to be left on glassware
also generally speaking about detergents
it's important to note
that if you do have a specific type of
contaminant
there are certain ph levels that are
going to better suit
cleaning when trying to clean heavy
scales
a ph of them zero to two so
very acidic is is recommended for salt
oxides and metallics
two to five point five is generally
generally acceptable so mildly mildly
acidic
for the more neutral ph range that's
going to be
a lot light oils and particulates
mild alkaline detergent so 8.5 to 11
are going to be for your slightly hearty
oils and films
more alkaline so that 11 to 12.5 are
going to be for natural oils
fats and resins and then
heavy greases and soils are going to be
best cleaned at a ph of 12
12.5 or higher
so next we've talked about contaminants
we've talked about
detergents or selecting the right
detergents it's important to understand
the substrate that you're trying to to
clean
uh those contaminants off of there are
various substrate types
more or less most laboratories or
religions can be concerned with the
plastic stainless steel and glass but i
did want to mention aluminum and other
soft metals
these tend to be
best washed with detergents in a ph
range of 2.5 to 9.5
moving on to mild steel really the thing
to focus on there is that the corrosion
is controlled
by completely rinsing and drying these
pieces
moving on to plastics not surprisingly
plastics can stand up to a broader range
of aqueous
cleaners
stainless steel generally are going to
be best cleaned in
alkaline detergents ranging from
a ph of 10 to 14
and then glass specifically borosilicate
glass again
very resistant can stand up to a wide
range of detergents
so really the next question is why
should my laboratory
or any laboratory implement a glassware
washer
it's always important to keep in mind
that these glassware washers were
designed
with laboratories in mind these washers
generally consist
of pretty robust hardy components that
can provide greater performance whether
it be
the wash pump drain pump spray arms
with these these better performing
components
it also comes with a increased
reliability
they can withstand the the fluctuations
in the high heat needed to
to adequately clean glassware also this
provides an opportunity to standardize
and automate the messy unwanted task of
cleaning glassware
also the construction of these units is
built to withstand harsh laboratory
conditions and environments
and also worth mentioning this limits
the expo
the exposure for laboratory
professionals
to incur workplace injuries with broken
glass
so really what questions should you be
asking if you're in the market for
buying a new glassware washer updating
an old one
really the first thing you should look
for is the incorporation of 304
stainless steel or better
three or four would be basically the
gold standard i
do see some manufacturers that offer
316 stainless steel
that being said next you want to see a
less of a dependence on
plastic components plastic components
obviously tend to break down much faster
than steel
when it comes to physical components
such as circulation pumps
you're really looking for the
circulation rate i would say the
baseline gold standard circulation rate
was going to be around
96 gallons per minute
some manufacturers do have a separate
drain pump
to drain the water versus using the same
pump to
drain and circulate for those that are
really concerned
about contamination i would explore the
option of finding manufacturers that can
separate those two
out when it comes to
water temperature
the minimum temperature you want to see
to sanitize is 74 degrees celsius
several minor manufacturers can easily
get to
82 degrees celsius 93 degrees celsius
and
can even go to as high as 99 degrees
celsius
so it's really whatever you're looking
for to really penetrate
soften and remove those contaminants on
that glassware
other things to consider are going to be
direct direct injection and this is just
really just a commentary on
what kind of glassware you're trying to
wash some laboratories are going to rely
heavily on wide mouth glassware and that
could be beakers
bowls other things like that whereas
other laboratories may have more
erlenmeyer flask more kel doll flask
things that are narrow necking
in nature so the washing
method has to change spray arms the
upper and lower will do a great job with
beakers
for those narrow neck glasswares you're
going to look for
manufacturers that can offer direct
injection washing and drying
not only will that make sure that inside
of those flats are clean but it will
make sure those inside of those flats
are also dry when it comes to drying
temperatures it's also
fair fair to ask
to see a drying temperature of 70 to 80
degrees celsius and this will
quickly dry glassware completely
next when it comes to even pure water
rinses to make sure you're getting any
residual contaminants off that glassware
it's
definitely a question that you need to
ask do i need this
the benefit of implementing pure water
rinses is that
it's another level or another step taken
to completely remove contaminants from
glassware to ensure that
when these are reused that you don't
have to worry about introducing
contaminants to your workflows
oftentimes pure water pumps will come
as pressurized or non-pressurized really
the only thing
to be aware of there is that you need to
have a pressurized
source of pure water for those
leveraging
non-pressurized pumps you can use
carboys or storage bladders or
or really whatever however you store
your tank
next it's always it's always fair to ask
the question
how is how am i going to interact with
this and how is that experience
going to help me on a daily basis a lot
of manufacturers are updating and we're
moving away from
push button and controls and we're
starting with touch screens
that offer robust features that are
very user friendly and it makes sense to
use it
the way or it's instinctive
on how to use the washer
by implementing updated controls
this allows several manufacturers to
provide
extensive data logging and export
features just for documentation
which again very important
when proving or recording any results
that you may need to at a later date
also it's worth mentioning that
washers should have clear alarms you
shouldn't have to essentially
go find the user manual reference a
table
just to find out what alarm it is that
that should be clear present and you
should know exactly what you're dealing
with
the the second you're interacting with
that that unit
also worth mentioning if you have any
specific requirements or special
features that you need
oftentimes hepa filter drying or i'm
sorry hepa filter force air drying
is is a an option that can be added onto
washers and that's just going to go
ahead and filter out potential air
contaminants
during that drying process um also for
those that need to have
or keep an eye on water quality
conducts conduct conductivity sensing
for measuring water quality is
a feature that is commonly used and
leveraged
also it's worth mentioning that water
softeners
are being incorporated into these
washers as well for those
sites that have
water supply quality issues so if they
have like super hard water
moving on a no washer is complete
without a robust ecosystem of
accessories
these accessories are going to help
help maximize cleanability help you
store
as much glassware to make sure it's
oriented the correct way so you get the
correct cleaning
also it will help with specialty
glassware like graduated cylinders
and volumetric pipettes to make sure
those are cleaned and reusable
all right so just to recap on my final
slide you guys
i think it's important to identify
potential sources of contamination
what kind kind of contamination you can
run into what you're trying
to wash from a substrate perspective
and then why implementing a glassware
washer
can help save a laboratory professionals
time
automating standardizing the messy
unwanted tasks of cleaning glassware
helping produce repeatable reliable
cleanability
when it comes to your glassware
standardizing that resource consumption
so from a water and electric standpoint
and then
limiting potential exposure to workplace
injuries as well
so again thank you so much for your guys
time
i'm ready to field any questions that
you guys may have
when it comes to glassware washing
thank you jordan for that informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
now let's get started our first question
is
what option do you have for washing
pipettes
um so that's a great question uh really
the
most glassware manufacturers are going
to have specialized inserts for
pipettes this can range from
oh gasketed tubes to gasketed blocks
that actually directly
connect to the glassware washer racks
that'll provide that direct injection of
of water and air
for washing and drying so so that's
generally how most manufacturers handle
it
okay thank you got another question here
what are some common contaminants found
on labware
oh some common contaminants are going to
be
obviously residual reagents in actual
samples
that you were testing in a lot of the
times i do notice
glassware that's generally used to
heat boil various chemical mixtures
tends to
to be pretty sticky and gunky on that
glassware so it's obviously important to
get that off
if if we are using uh going to reuse
that glassware
um me also being the product manager of
our kelvol solution um i do manage to
see a lot of kelball flasks that
tend to contain a lot of fibrous and
and gunky material from that acid acid
digestion process
so yeah those are just a few of a few of
the common contaminants that i've seen
in my experience
okay we've got another question here
what is a contaminant sensitive
method commonly used in a laboratory
setting
um so a contaminant
sensitive method that's going to be used
in a laboratory setting most likely is
going to be your hplc
that's really a pretty robust
technique that can be used in a variety
of markets and sectors to do
a variety of different workflows so that
workflow can also be used to actually
validate
cleaning procedures as well for those
that need to do that
to really make sure that they're using
contaminant-free glassware so yeah
okay thank you jordan i have another
question this is the last question from
the audience
um what role does detergent play in
removing labware contaminants
another great question um so really when
it comes to
how detergent and glassware washers um
play it's really kind of a synergistic
relationship
obviously that glassware washer is going
to be spraying water heating water
it really used to dislodge any sticky
contaminants on that glassware
however that detergent is also going to
play a key role into breaking down and
emulsifying and
and scrubbing those stubborn
contaminants that
are baked on cooked on boiled on
in that glassware so it's really kind of
the one-two punch that laboratories
really need
um when trying to clean that dirty
glassware
and get reliably clean glassware on a
daily basis
great thank you i've got another
question here from the audience
what are some methods for raising or
lowering the ph of a wash or rinse
especially to become more basal
um so uh for lowering the ph
of the rent it's important to always use
an acid neutralizing rinse
um a lot of the times
generally wash water tends to get a
little more acidic obviously when you're
washing
washing contaminants off of glassware so
it's important to
neutralize that during the rinse cycle
just by
leveraging acid neutralizing rinses
okay thank you jordan i have another
question here from the audience
can i wash plastic items
um yeah so it's always important um
to know what you can and can't wash um
obviously plastic is going to be
a little more sensitive to the higher
temperatures
it's always important to ask that
question especially to who
or where you got that plastic from to
see if there is or any specific
temperature requirements
for the most part plastic polymers and
those plastic utensils that you can use
and
that you can also reuse generally do a
pretty good job nowadays of standing up
to
high pressure washing and high
temperature water and heating and drying
as well so
thank you jordan that's the last of our
questions so i want to thank you
for your time today do you have any
final comments for our audience
um no i just wanted to again reiterate
thank you for your time
today um it was a pleasure to present to
you guys
i hope you guys um learned something
found it informative and then of course
if you have any additional questions
please don't hesitate to to reach out to
us or visit our website at
www.labconco.com
and we'd be more than happy to help you
out
well thank you again jordan for your
time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labrutz and
our sponsor labconco for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
a survey will be displayed on your
screen shortly your participation is
greatly appreciated
until next time goodbye